all right welcome to the live stream so
much to talk about yesterday's live
stream was short-circuited by a
delightful DDoS attack on the David
Pakman show website if you watched
yesterday I did a debate with
independent journalist Tim Poole and
once it wrapped up we were going to
consider opening the phone lines and bla
bla bla bla bla and members and all of
this stuff and then people started
saying David we're trying to sign up for
membership in order for you to open up
the phone lines as it says down there
and your websites down and it was indeed
a DDoS attack it's delightful little
thing which happened happened once well
I mean it's happened a couple of times
actually maybe I shouldn't even call
attention to why or when but the timing
may be coincidental after the Tim Poole
debate maybe not I don't know you be the
judge but we had a nice little powwow
with our hosting company and our web
developer and things are back up and
running fortunately and hopefully
they'll hold so that we can actually
open up the phone lines today while I'm
waiting for people to get connected
we're going to be talking about the Don
Jr subpoena momentarily I have been just
engrossed in the book bad blood by John
Kerry rue or carry you I don't know if
that last R is silent it is an
extraordinary piece of investigative
journalism about the scam that is
Elizabeth Holmes company Thera notes
which it is it is a book that has been
written on the basis of hundreds of
interviews and such extraordinarily good
investigative journalism we're trying to
get John Kerry Rouen on the show and the
paperback of the book bad blood is
coming out in a couple of months so
we're hoping to get him on absolutely
fantastic nonfiction and I highly highly
recommend it to you it's 300 pages and I
think I started three days ago and I'm
on page 250 because I just am unable to
put it down engrossing well done as
investigative journalism and just a
captivating story of scammers and Liars
and deception and anyway check it out
because it's truly truly extraordinary
okay welcome to the live stream if this
is your first live stream these are
different than the YouTube clips that I
upload in that this is live unless
you're watching a replay meaning you can
communicate with me directly best way to
do it is use the super chat function
that's the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window type in a comment ask a
question and we will put those up on the
screen I will answer the questions and I
will react to the comments excellent
excellent way to participate in the live
stream if you want me to open the phone
lines and allow people to call in our
number is six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty then sign up for
membership on our website there are
discounts full price is a great deal
discounts make it even better coupon
codes down in the video description if
we get 10 new members we will open the
phone lines and hear from people please
don't troll the live chat we will ban
people we have moderators who have been
deputized and they know what to watch
for I think we all know what counts as
trolling and you can also use the join
button down below to become a Youtube
subscriber if that is something you want
just as an example of what super chat
looks like Jose Romero has sent the
first super chat of the evening and it
pops up on the screen just like that
it's delightful it's fun for the entire
family and eventually I will answer his
question but let's get directly into the
sort of lead story for this evening
which is that yes indeed our buddy Don
jr. oh man does this zoom on this this
is not good how can I put this on the
screen might have to do some cropping
here every that this always seems to go
haywire no matter what uh what I try let
me see if I can crop this a little bit
to give us some space let's see here if
I go like this and then move it over I
think that that'll work
a little bit better for us yeah and then
maybe I can zoom it in uh yes no maybe
so okay I think that helps Senate
Intelligence Committee has subpoenaed
Trump jr. over Russia matters so
I think that this is a really
interesting strategic move if you are a
Democrat who is in favor of this but
remember that this is the republican-led
Senate and thus the Republican
intelligence Republican led Senate
Intelligence Committee and that's a
consideration here that we don't want to
ignore but let's start at the top the
Republican led Senate Intelligence
Committee has subpoenaed Donald Trump
Union to answer questions about his
previous testimony before Senate
investigators in relation to the Russia
investigation sources with direct
knowledge told Axios why it matters it's
the first congressional subpoena that we
know about of one of president Trump's
children the subpoena sets up a fight
that's unprecedented in the Trump era a
Republican committee chair pit against
the Republican presidents eldest son
it's also a sign that the Russia
investigations in Congress aren't over
despite the conclusion of special
counsel robert molars probe and despite
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
saying it's time to move on from the
Russia probe a Senate Intelligence
Committee spokesperson told Axios we do
not discuss the details of witness
engagements with the committee
throughout the investigation the
committee has reserved the right to
recall witnesses for additional
testimony as needed as every witness and
witness counsel has been made aware Don
and Senate Intel agreed from the very
beginning that he would appear once to
testify before the committee and would
remain for as long as it took to answer
all of their questions he did that were
not sure why we're fighting with
Republicans a source close to Trump jr.
told Axios so before we go any further
don't underestimate the the willingness
of Republicans to concoct political
theater to get Donald Trump jr. there to
to testify about how fine everything is
and how there's nothing to see
and everything's totally fine no
collusion no obstruction you're the
victim your dad's the victim everybody's
a victim at the same time this will
allow Democrats to ask questions of
Donald Trump jr. under oath in a setting
that could be extraordinarily explosive
and and interesting for the purposes of
figuring out how dumb is this guy first
of all which is maybe one of the one of
the top questions I'd have about Don jr.
but also what does he say about
a variety of relevant matters so there's
a couple of different ways that this
could go if and if it happens molar
whose investigation did not find a
conspiracy between the Trump campaign
and Russia did not indict Trump jr.
despite speculation that he would
unlike many congressional investigations
in the Trump era the Senate Intelligence
probe led by Republican Chairman Richard
Burr and Democratic vice chair mark
Warner has been largely bipartisan if
there is one place where Republicans are
in charge but there is the possibility
that there might be productive and
serious discussion about the truth of
what took place over the last two and a
half years it would be the Senate
Intelligence Committee there's no
question about that out of
republican-led committees and
investigative bodies the fact that their
subpoenaing Trump jr. is a strong signal
that he declined a request to appear
before the committee again that that's
interesting which is if so when you
testify before these Senate committees
they will often tell you that's it for
today but we reserve the right to call
you back in whatever language they use
for that if Don Jr already appeared
after an on subpoena request and now
there is a subpoena it is not crazy to
think to infer that maybe he has refused
an invitation that is a non subpoena
request and now they have sort of been
there hand has been forced into issuing
this subpoena the back story Trump jr.
testified now I'm going to another page
accidentally apologies there Trump jr.
testified before the Senate Judiciary
Committee in September of 17 that he was
only peripherally peripherally aware of
proposed plans for the Moscow project
his testimony was released he testified
for a total of more than 25 hours with
three different committees per source
familiar with the situation in an
interview with Fox News's Laura Ingraham
in January Trump jr. downplayed his
knowledge of the discussions of a
possible Trump Tower Moscow saying the
project was a creation of president
Trump's former attorney Michael Cohen we
don't know anything about it ultimately
it was Michael Cohen essential
trying to get a deal done as we know
Michael Cohen oh and here it is Michael
Cohen claimed in his testimony before
the Oversight Committee that Trump jr.
was more aware of the project than that
during the 16 campaign Cohen testified
he briefed jr. and Ivanka about the
proposed Trump Tower Moscow project
about ten times we know the project was
formalized in a letter of intent and
BuzzFeed reported and actually published
architectural plans and drawings showing
what the tower would have looked like
the proposed location of the tower etc
etc etc I would love to see jr. testify
if in if it had were to happen publicly
and it may not that's an important thing
even if he agrees he may not do it
publicly because he's not particularly
bright and if you've ever seen him
appear on the sean hannity show you
probably know what i'm talking about and
it would be very interesting to see how
he handles a variety of the topics that
are likely to come up he would be of
course he would have an attorney sitting
right behind him and that would sort of
limit the likelihood that he would say
extraordinarily stupid things but
regardless it would be very very
interesting to see and I hope that we do
get it so that is what's going on with
Don Jr let me take a look and see if
people want me to do before I move on to
the next story I guess I'll do a couple
of Super chats that have been coming in
or actually no you know what let's just
move to the next story right away
because the super chats are coming in
fast and furious new memberships are
coming in fast and furious and I'm gonna
want to get to all of that stuff so
let's continue with the next story
Donald Trump is now claiming executive
privilege over the full Moeller report
this is related to the House of
Representatives Judiciary Committee
voting to recommend that William Bar be
held in contempt of Congress for not
turning over an unredacted version of
the Moller
report the committee voted 24 to 16 this
was taken after hours of debate that
featured apocalyptic language about the
future of American democracy this is the
first time the house has taken official
action to punish a government official
or witness
amid a standoff between the legislative
and executive branch Justice Department
decried it as an unnecessary and
overwrought reaction designed to stoke a
fight that's that's that's what sort of
triggered Donald Trump to now assert
privilege Carrie ku Peck a spokeswoman
for the Justice Department responded
quote the accommodation process between
co-equal branches of government is
supposed to be a two-way street
unfortunately the only side who has made
accommodations as the Attorney General
what a laughable claim who made
extraordinary efforts extraordinary to
provide Congress and the public with
information about the special council's
work the executive privilege assertion
was mr. Trump's first use of the secrecy
powers as president the Justice
Department described it as protective to
allow Trump time to fully review the
materials to make a final privileged
determination it's been more than a
month but the timing of the assertion
signaled that the White House is eager
for a fight and the White House press
secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders indicated that no
change of heart was coming the American
people see through chairman Adler's
desperate ploy does distract from the
president's historically successful
agenda lie and our booming economy she
said in a statement neither the White
House nor Attorney General bar will
comply with Chairman Nadler as unlawful
and reckless demands nothing unlawful
about them of course she added that
faced with chairman Adler's blatant
abuse of power and at the Attorney
General's request the president has no
other option than to make a protective
assertion of executive privilege so it's
gonna be a fight and it's gonna be a
very interesting fight and here's where
I kind of come down on this you can make
the case that this is a fight that on
the the sort of details and the
logistics on the procedure may never
have a clear winner
that is a very possible and even
plausible or likely scenario that this
goes on and on and on and we get to the
November 20 2011 Affinia shtup I still
think that that's a win for Democrats
and a win for those who want to see
from lose in 2020 because you've got to
remember a lot of Americans through no
fault of their own stagnant wages
they've got to work they've got to get
their kids to school as I like to say
somebody may have just one david pakman
show bingo um they haven't read the
molar report they haven't gone through
the absolutely devastating footnotes in
the molar report and so they hear about
the bar letter they see the exoneration
public relations campaign of no
collusion no obstruction totally cleared
of course it's all untrue but they don't
look at the molar report so all of these
battles the battle over whether Trump
can assert privilege subpoenaing Don
junior to go back to the Senate
Intelligence panel fighting for an
unredacted version of the report
impeachment debate in the House of
Representatives which should start
immediately I'm not saying go to
articles of impeachment I'm saying start
a floor debate about impeachment
immediately which will push a lot of the
content of the Moller report on to
corporate media and get people informed
about what's in there
even if legally speaking it leads to
nothing and that's the most likely
scenario as I've been saying now for how
long have I been saying it it's still
good because people don't know what is
in the molar report I get people calling
me all the time who want to argue with
me about the molar report they haven't
actually read the molar report they've
not looked at it and there are there's
no shortage of people who out of bad
faith or in good faith are have formed
opinions about the full content of the
report without actually having looked at
it based solely on Trump's exoneration
campaign so I think that this is a good
thing and we will see where it all altum
Utley leads okay let me say hello and
welcome a couple of people this this
people might find very interesting
the newest David Pakman show member is
Jimmy from Philly
the violent violent language that is I
don't know anything about him being
being physically violent I want to be
clear
aggressive drinks too much landscaper
from Philadelphia who calls me all the
time he or someone claiming to be him no
it is actually his email that's
interesting Jimmy from Philly is now a
David Pakman show
remember if someone who despises
everything that this program stands for
so much is willing to sign up and throw
a couple bucks a month at what we're
doing what about all of the people who
agree with what we're doing and actually
like progressive independent media
welcome to Jimmy from Philly the newest
David Pakman show member that's one if
we get to ten new members like it says
down below I will open the phone lines
at six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty our phone bill this month is
gonna be off the charts April 2019 set a
record for our phone bill beating all
previous months but it's only the eighth
of the month and we are very clearly on
track particularly if the phone lines
open today
for setting another phone bill record
maybe someday I'll tell you how much it
is but it's the reason why we do new
member drives when I do these extra live
streams we will get those phone lines
open if we get 10 new members to coupon
codes available you can use the coupon
code this is 20 20 slap that thing on to
any membership and it'll drop the price
forty percent if you want like an extra
good deal you can use the coupon code
save thirty five and that'll drop a
sixty dollar membership that's the
yearly to just twenty five dollars and
that's a really really exciting thing
for everybody so I'll keep thanking
people as they sign up okay let me get
to some of the super chats that have
come in let's start with Jose Romero who
said with a dollar ninety nine super
Chad who will be the first Democrats to
drop out in 2020 let's actually let's
take a look I want to look at let me
pull it up Democratic primary pulls and
I'll pull these up once I have them and
I know everybody disagrees with the
validity of many of these polls and all
of that stuff but we're just gonna we're
just gonna play it out as if we could
trust these okay so the you zoom out a
bit here and this website is a mess
okay Real Clear Politics latest poll is
the morning consult poll let me zoom it
in actually here we go
it has Biden forty Sanders nineteen
Warren eight Harris seven Buddha judge
six or orc five Booker three Klobuchar
two gap
one Castro one yang one Rian one and
Ensley zero listen
looking at this I don't know how much
longer it's gonna make sense for Inslee
to stay and Hickenlooper isn't even
showing up in this thing I don't know
what the benefit for him staying and
much longer is Tim Ryan I mean okay I
like the guy I met him personally it
just if you look at the polls it's not
looking good who Leon Castro has just
never gotten going at all Tulsi Gabbard
I mean one is even a stretch he's
polling zero in a bunch of different
polls if you go back just a little bit
to one poll over the weekend Gabbard and
Castro our polling zero so I think that
everybody who as far as I know of the
people here who aren't polling well I
believe Yang and Gabbard have made it to
the debate stage or are close to so I
don't think anybody's gonna drop out
before the debates if they're in the
debates because that's good publicity
for them but a lot of these people
polling zero or one I think it's
anyone's guess who goes first but a lot
of them are gonna start going I think
there's no doubt about it
mavis Leyva's says David and
short-sleeves oh my goodness yeah that's
right I'm wearing short sleeves and what
else can I say not I mean that's it I'm
wearing short sleeves it's getting warm
getting warm in Boston and your name
says David why are you always
adversarial with AOC on Twitter I don't
know what you're talking about
did you see her co-sponsor a bill that
would help coal miners she's the only
Congress person doing her job I think
that's great if you've referred a during
my I do like five minutes of Twitter in
the morning and five minutes in the
afternoon that's all I do on Twitter now
because it's toxic
I saw her post about right-wing
youtubers that are funded by right-wing
by Republican donors I want to know
about that I want I genuinely asked her
I want to know who is funded other than
ben shapiro by republican donors because
i'm not aware of that like his crowder
being funded by big isn't even Canadian
but our American right-wingers funding
him I would be interested in knowing
about that Nabil Kaveri says hey David
hope everything is well and that you're
feeling good on this beautiful Wednesday
what are your favorite genres of books
also sorry for getting heated yester
jiae's livestream I don't I don't know
what you're talking about I don't know
what happened on yesterday's livestream
and a deal with you but my favorite
genres of fiction are literary fiction
mysteries and thrillers and sci-fi
historical fiction crime fiction
I'm not into let me let me give you so
I'll give you like the pro - I don't
even know that this is a real book okay
but like this is the the type of fiction
book I'm not into a heartwarming tale of
a young woman's coming of age and the
discovery that she has a passion for
painting wildflowers in watercolor okay
I don't know if that book really exists
that's not my thing
that that's just not the type of fiction
that I'm into yeah okay I don't know
what else I can add to that
J H WH good ol with a ten euro super
chat which i think is the biggest sue so
ten euro is definitely more than ten
dollars yeah that's the high-water mark
for the evening
oops uh and now it got moved in Austria
far-right FPO
gained in Parliament but in election for
labor unions and federal chamber of
employees the social demper sent FPO
only ten percent fpou can't be trusted
on social issues okay adding with
another ten euro super chat that's like
twenty four US dollars total chamber for
employees every employee pays zero point
five percent of gross wage gets you
juridical help against your employer or
gives council maternity leave child
benefits etc without additional cost us
equals weird yeah I don't know anything
about any of the stuff you're talking
about it those US for Austria and
details but what I can tell you is that
it is depressing on a daily level that a
lot of the things that other countries
have figured out we just seem unable to
take care of in the United States the
progressive voice does Tim Poole ever
wash his beanie I've never seen him wash
it but if it's wool you got to be
careful because that you can't dry it
and there
be some care requirements you know we'd
have to look at the tag on the underside
to really know what the proper technique
is as he may even have multiple beanies
that look the same you know and that and
and so he may even be throwing them out
his his business is quite successful of
course and he may have the capital to
just by 365 beanies and toss one out
every day I don't know
art Flores says we hang the petty
thieves and appoint the great ones to
public office Aesop uh all right I think
we could apply that in a number of ways
to what's going on in modern politics
Arielle Fernandez says do you think the
head of state and the head of government
should be two different people or the
same person like in the United States of
America uh you know I think it would be
very interesting to see them separate in
the United States this is of course
imagining that we there would be the
political will to actually do that and
it's not at all clear to me that there
is but I like the idea of it being two
different people while at the same time
I don't want one of those two people to
be some kind of monarch right so but yes
if it's the right thing and not not not
putting in people on the basis of family
lineage $1 super chat was sent and then
retracted enter name could you see
yourself voting for a Oh see if she ran
in 2028 I have no idea
not if she had no additional experience
or knowledge relative to what she has
today I would say no if she develops
political knowledge and builds
achievements and whatnot over the next
nine years then why would I rule her out
certainly it'd be it'd be somebody that
I would consider okay let me say thanks
to a couple of other people as I
mentioned earlier you can sign up for
membership on our website there are two
coupon codes available and if we have
ten people sign up during the live
stream I will open up the phone lines at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty this is really
embarrassing right now for the left
unfortunately the only new member of the
evening is a toxic right winger who
calls into the show named Jimmy from
Philly Jimmy from Philly who seems to
love Trump and defense Trump every time
he calls me is the only person who has
signed up for a membership and no
lefties because nobody else has signed
up yet have decided that hey you know
what independent media is important and
I'm gonna support it with a couple of
bucks so that is that's depressing but
one thing I will offer is if you are
interested in calling in if you sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
include your area code not your zip code
as some people erroneously do that
doesn't help me figure out who you are
when you callin if you include your area
code in either the first name or the
last name field in addition to your
first and last name i will make a note
i've got a whole bunch of new yellow
legal pads that i keep here for you know
taking notes about the quality of a
callers connection and all of this sort
of stuff I will write down your area
code so that when we open the phone
lines you will get priority you will get
special handling and I will go to you
right away
and as I mentioned to coupon codes
available this is twenty twenty saves
you 40% off of any membership save
thirty five drops a $60 membership to
just twenty five bucks that's two
dollars in eight cents a month I think
most folks in the audience can afford
that and membership is the number one
funding source for the show James boo
Chino says why do you believe a OC is
uninformed for president listen I think
lots of people are uninformed for
President Xi has basic misunderstandings
about economic concepts which we've
covered geopolitical concepts it's not
an attack on her I don't think she's a
bad person
but I would like to be voting for
someone that I feel has a firmer grasp
on just like basic economics basic
history basic foreign policy and I'm
talking about her because people are
asking me about her but
same analysis would apply to a whole
bunch of people who are in elected
office Arielle Fernandez says yeah if
it's to different people than the United
States would have to likely become a
parliamentary system or a semi semi
presidential system yeah that was
exactly my thought Arielle which is in
theory I love the idea of two different
people as head of government and head of
state there would need to be other more
significant changes to how government is
organized in the u.s. in order to allow
that to sort of integrate cleanly into
the way that other elements of
government work couple other articles
and stories I wanted to talk about we're
going to be covering this on the program
tomorrow so I'm not going to go into
full detail on it but there's a very
interesting article in The Guardian
about the level of climate change denial
that is happening in the United States
there is a very short list of countries
that has more climate denial than the
United States
it's Saudi Arabia and Indonesia not
usually countries that we sort of
consider ourselves similar to the u.s.
is a hotbed of climate science denial
when compared with other countries
international polling finds a
significant number of Americans don't
believe human driven climate change is
occurring a total of thirteen percent of
Americans polled in a 23 country survey
conducted by YouGov Cambridge globalism
project agreed with the statement that
the climate is changing but human
activity is not responsible at all a
further 5% straight up said the climate
was not changing only Saudi Arabia at
16% and Indonesia at 18% had a higher
proportion of people doubtful of manmade
climate change this is so depressing
Indonesia Saudi Arabia US followed by
Mexico Australia Poland Germany China
France Britain it's a very interesting
because you've got Indonesia and Saudi
Arabia the United States Mexico which is
a spanish-speaking mostly Catholic
country not known for having
like this nationalist right-wing
uprising you have Australia which has
been dealing with some of these
nationalist right-wing movements as has
Poland as has Germany China is a country
that has fundamental information access
issues and I wonder if that's related
there and then you have France and
Britain which have also been dealing
with a sort of a rise in right-wing
nationalist type nonsense so I'm not
finding any common thread that that sort
of pervades all of the countries that
are at the top here now admittedly when
you get down to Britain like it's only a
sample of 23 countries once you get down
to I guess it's number 10 Britain it's
already it looks like only 4% of the of
the population that are climate deniers
which is really quite low Americans were
also more likely than any other Western
country polled
to say they did not know whether the
climate was changing or whether people
were responsible a total of 13 percent
said this but despite these views the
great majority of American citizens do
accept the science of climate denial
nearly 4 and 10 say human activity was
at least partially responsible
potentially along with other factors a
further third taking the stronger view
that human activity is the dominant
cause I don't know that I need to
mention this but scientists
overwhelmingly agree that people are
causing climate change through the
exponential increase of greenhouse gas
emissions over the years why do we excel
at stuff that's horrible I mean really
you know when you look at the wealthy
Western countries as we might call them
the United States is the one that has
high spending and poor health care
outcomes high spending on health care
and low health care outcomes we're
falling behind on math and science we
increasingly are dealing with issues
like climate climate science denial and
anti-vaccine sentiment and on and on and
on they were infant mortality among the
rich Western countries the United States
fares very poorly we're leading the way
in a lot of things that we should not be
proud of and unfortunately I don't see
it changing anytime soon and unless
things drastically drastically change at
a cultural level
in this country and given the fact that
30% of the country approves if the job
37% of the country approves that the job
Trump is doing hard to imagine that
that's gonna happen anytime soon okay
we're finally contesting Jimmy from
Philly as the only new member of the
evening Christopher Grove has become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and because things are getting a
little desperate we will count patreon
donors towards our goal of 10
Nabeel Kivar e has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
40% off coupon code this is 20/20 Ian
Ewing has signed up as a member at david
pakman.com slash membership Ian I think
was formerly a member and it's great to
have you back Leonardo Bravo
has signed that way I'm losing track so
we've got Jimmy and the YouTube guy and
then Nabil and Ian and Leonardo is
number 5 Leonardo Bravo has signed up as
a member at david pakman.com slash
membership using the save 35 coupon code
which drops a $60 membership to just 25
bucks let me see who else we've got here
number 6 is Norma Palacios Norma
Palacios is new member number 6 and
David Santana is new member number 7
from the 703 area code I will make a
note of that on my yellow pad so if the
phone lines get opened 703 if by the way
you're just in the 703 area code it
would be very easy for you to trick me
into picking you up very quickly but I'm
gonna make a note 703 David Santana and
he will be first on the phones if indeed
we open them up we are at 7 new members
like it says down their phone lines will
open when we get to 10 new members it's
really cheap
okay this is my please clap moment it's
really cheap please sign up please sign
up what it's our number one funding
source our phone bill gets bigger every
month as every time I open the phone
lines we end up having 50 60 people
holding and that's
that gets that gets pricey all right so
if we get three three more Hugh members
I'll open up the phone lines Ariel or
let's see what's gonna let me go up here
Luke Eva sends a six dollar super chat
no question or comment
Federico Cunha says what do you think of
what's happening in Argentina which
thing I'm from Argentina and I watch and
follow Argentinean news every day but
there's a lot of different things
happening in Argentina so you'll have to
be more specific do you mean the fact
that there's a president in Argentina
who's buddy-buddy with Trump and he is
arguably a better option than the
formerly completely corrupt and
disgusting cristina kirchner that
mockery is all is a better option as
disgusting as he is do you mean the
inflation and the absolute crash of the
Argentinean peso relative to the dollar
you know we could go on and on a lot of
problems the fact that a bunch of the
country still has no running water tell
me which problem you mean and I'll dig
into it Ariel Fernandez says in some
countries the head of state is mostly a
ceremonial figurehead with little to no
executive power Ireland is an example of
one of those countries indeed and even
in those cases I don't want it to be a
monarch Matthew tpc says why is Bernie
digging a hole on felons voting I'm not
aware of him digging a hole let me look
at if he said anything recently Bernie
Sanders felons voting um
Bernie's right let prisoners vote you
know I don't know that I agree that he's
digging a hole I've said before for me
it's super super clear that most of the
people that are felons should not have
their right to vote revoked I think
you've got edge cases in the cases of
people who have no possibility of parole
meaning they're never going to be
participants in society again should
they have the right to vote but are we
really saying that you know if you're in
prison for dealing cannabis if you are
on a second defense for something
relatively minor I mean what why should
you lose your right to vote I actually
think Bernie is mostly right on it I
think he sometimes gets lulled into
losing debates on the issue but I think
he is mostly right and I think that
there are complex cases edge cases we
we should actually have a bigger
conversation about Arielle Fernandez
says we will probably have to amend the
Constitution of the United States of
America
all right that's something we made up
may have to do Dark Annihilator says
Kyle I assume you mean Kyle kolinsky
Kyle says Dems shouldn't impeach Trump
because it would help Trump win he also
says the Moller report proves Russian
hysteria what are your thoughts I am
taking your word for that
I don't know what Kyle is saying about
any of this stuff I think that there is
a political strategy consideration when
it comes to impeachment of Trump so my
my immediate advice is debate on
impeachment should start right away
debate on impeachment should start on
the start on the floor of the house
right away to get into corporate media
the content of the Moller report which
is devastating to Donald Trump
many Americans aren't going to look at
the molar report for 48 pages that over
a thousand footnotes so let's debate
impeachment in the house to get evidence
out into corporate media and then make a
decision I think it is possible that
actually trying to impeach Trump
particularly without Republican support
in the Senate meaning they're not going
to vote to remove them could could
actually emboldened the right so I think
he Kyl if I'm understanding your
understanding of what he said correctly
may be on to something
Kyle also says the Moller report proves
Russian hysteria I don't know what that
means but the Moller report has
confirmed basically every serious
assertion and major investigative
journalism story of the last two years
Zenda crusts has a $5 Super chat
Buddhist nationalists in Southeast Asia
have attacked Muslims for years without
retaliation till the sri lankan bombings
will violence escalate now I don't know
I hope it doesn't I'm against violence
of all kinds I'm against religious based
violence I'm against political violence
and I hope that that does not happen
okay we have another new member which
gets us to eight for the evening and
that is John Gebhardt John Gabe
is signed up at full price thanks John
really appreciate it also want to say
hello to Simon GUI Doan gede own who is
new member number 9 of the evening I
really hope that we are not going to
fail to open the phone lines at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 just one new member short of
10 that would be that would be very
depressing including for David Santana
from the 703 area code who included his
area code when he signed up meaning he
gets priority when we opened the phone
lines if you want to call in and talk to
me like now I mean we'll we were only
one new member away when you sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership in the
first or last name field that will come
up after you hit the sign up button
enter your area code so like if I was
David Pakman and my phone number was
imagine that it was six one seven a
common Boston area code when I sign up I
would put first name David six one seven
last name Pakman and then when it comes
through I will write your name down on
my yellow pad right now it only has one
name David Santana 703 and then when we
open the phone lines I will go to you
directly so one more member and we will
get those phone lines opened up okay
Ariel Fernandez adds the head of state
of the Republic of violet of Ireland is
a directly elected president the head of
state doesn't have to be a monarch like
in the United Kingdom
absolutely not suggesting that it must
be a monarch simply making clear that I
am NOT for monarchy and I think most of
the most of the audience is aware of
that okay Wade Holmes has signed up
using YouTube membership that's number
10 and I also should say hi to Chad
Muhsin who is new member number 11 of
the evening and Ryan Gunn Yin or
Ghanaian who is new member number 12 of
the evening and Michael Garcia who is
new member number 13 of the evening
so let's get the phone lines opened and
oh oh and Michael wants to call in from
the 8:32 area code well we can make that
happen let me get the phone lines opened
make a note Michael Garcia from 8 3 2
the phone number is 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we
have two people who are going to get
extreme and total priority and you can
start calling it now at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 Ryan Gallagher sends a $20 super chat
very very generous hey Dave I love the
show I learn a lot and you're so cordial
but there are times when you can - salt
on your monologue on the perfect times
and it cracks me up if I said [ __ ]
McConnel that would be a Freudian slip
well that actually is a Freudian slip
that I had once on the program let me
see if I can find it would be funny to
see if I can I wonder if I search my own
YouTube channel for [ __ ] McConnell if
it will come up taking a look here no ok
so I'm not easily able to find it
unfortunately but yeah that's actually a
real Freudian slip that I had on the on
the show before
Alan Chamberlain is a new member number
14 of the evening thank you very much
and Khalil Ahmadi with a hundred Danish
Krone or super chat joined a bit late so
I don't know if you've done your take on
this but do you think Donald Trump jr.
will show up in court well he's been
subpoenaed to the Senate Intel committee
not to court and my guess is that if
there is a subpoena that it's because he
has already refused a non subpoena
request so I don't know if he's going to
appear but I certainly hope that he does
and Arai Suslov
asks if I've considered adding teal gels
I assume you mean teal gels behind me
right now I have blue I tried some
orange ones on a couple panels people
generally didn't like them so I got rid
of him and I have not I don't know if
teal and blue would work but it's
certainly something I would I would
consider okay I'll get back to the super
chats but I know that there are now
people holding on the phone who want to
talk and we've got new members who have
priority who want to talk I may
actually have to take a call from Jimmy
from Philly even though he's called in
before because he he signed up for
membership today during the livestream
which is incredible because he is a very
very aggressive from pused let's see six
one seven eight three zero
4750 also Alex Malone from six one zero
once priority on the phones who is a new
member number fifteen of the evening so
let's see so far I'm not actually seeing
other than Jimmy any of the other
callers on the phone
so let's first go to Jimmy Jimmy is a
new member
Jimmy how's it feel to be supporting
independent progressive media as a very
aggressive trumpet hey Jimmy Wow yeah
yeah oh you're on right now Jimmy oh
okay um I have to say David I think this
is a first for the David Pakman show I
think I'm the first verified censored
conservative to join the David Pakman
show
I don't know anything about the
censorship but you're certainly not yes
you do I can't type I can't I can't type
on your live streams or any of your
YouTube channels or super chat well here
you are I think you should consider
right and I agree to be a gentleman you
know is is there no forgiveness amongst
you progressives I think you should
consider lifting that Jimmy I really
don't know what you're talking about
I don't moderate the chat and I don't
delete comments or ban people on YouTube
well if you don't know then you do know
now because I just told you that I'm
banned I ever asserted that I know
you're asserting that yeah well you know
I proved to you on a live call what was
it a week ago all right well I'll look
into it listen if the moderators in the
chat have I don't know if you have the
authority I apologize to the moderator I
like that Jim I I publicly apologize
Ashley told one of them to blow me I
think that's what got me
I know that making amends is one of the
steps of a a and as I've told you but I
don't know if you are I hope you are
Jimmy yeah that beard David I'm sorry
what was that third beer third beer you
said okay and aren't those 11.5% yes yes
okay all right so it's like a sixth beer
really in a way but you never went over
my LSD admission yeah I mean I don't
really care about people using drugs
that help me it helps you get off
alcohol sort of yeah a little bit all
right Jimmy very good I will let you get
back to that great to hear from you as
always and I appreciate the support
don't have too many more of those beers
let me see 7:03 let me do a scan for the
priority phone callers 703 is not
currently on eight three two is so let's
go to our caller from the eight three
two eight three two is this Michael
Garcia hello yes hi how's it going good
whose is this is Michael Garcia oh it is
Michael thank you for your support I
appreciate it yeah it's no problem man
what's on your mind what you I was
wondering what what you think of the the
prospects of the Democrats who are who
are running on unless than progressive
platform as progressive well on the
basis of the polling I think Biden's the
non non progressive candidate who's got
the best shot I think that Biden
entering has basically torpedoed the
chances of any other establishment
centrist Democrat from winning like if
you're you know if you're Hickenlooper
if you are Inslee or Klobuchar I mean
with Biden in how what what is the
what's the sale of what what what's your
value proposition at this point right
because Biden is very similar and has a
better shot so why would anyone support
you yeah that's a good point I hadn't
really thought of that mm-hm
but you know like from a from a
political perspective you have to
imagine that like most people are going
to lean towards the center
right and so it it was I don't know
haven't it
what do you mean Hannibal leaned towards
the center like like like it's what kind
of like a like a regression towards the
mean right there like most mote you
would think that most people aren't
aren't very extreme one way or another
right well I mean I certainly would not
apply the word extreme I think that
there's just more and more progressive
ideas that are now mainstream ideas like
the government should provide some
health care to everybody even if they
can't pay for it there are people on the
right who want to frame that as an
extreme idea but it's real a pretty main
strength ertainly so it depends on how
we're characterizing it yeah you know
here in here in Texas which is where I'm
calling from
you know we've had I guess I think I
would I would imagine that work would
call himself a moderate maybe I hasn't
he been sort of trying to sell his
progressive credentials right yeah he
says you know I believe in capitalism
and stuff like that but I mean I don't
think that that's like necessarily a bad
thing you know he's it's it's his it's
his it's kind of his appeal you know
he's not like he's not your bernie he's
not and he's not like he's not that old
right he's not he's he's not like like a
career politician in any sense you know
I mean I think Beto is being hurt by
Biden though there's no question about
it
yeah okay all right listen Michael a
very interesting topic I appreciate your
calling I really appreciate your support
as well great to hear from you in Texas
yeah nice to talk to you David all right
pleasure okay I will go to the phones in
a moment but let me do a couple more
super chats Ariel Fernandez asked if I
have a favorite Argentinian singer not a
singer but there's a lot of Argentinian
bands I like including Leviticus goddess
if I would know so Cadillacs I could go
on I don't even know the names of all of
the singers from those bands but a lot
of good Argentinian bands blood in the
water says can the American Republic
survived the slow-moving coup from
authoritarian regimes who appear to be
waging a quiet war
against representative democracy you're
gonna have to be more specific my friend
and have to be a little more specific
want to know which ones you're thinking
of V says Mitch McConnell is an evil
decrepit draconian vampire undead
villain his real name is Lich McConnell
maybe you mean leech McConnell I'm not
sure Nature Boy
do you think Bernie winning the primary
over Biden is a real possibility and if
Biden were to win how likely is it that
he wins against trump okay I do is Biden
winning the primary over is Bernie
winning over Biden a possibility yes it
is if you look at the polls support is
going to consolidate among what I
believe are currently the top four
candidates probably and Bernie certainly
could win over Biden if Biden wins how
likely is it that he wins against Trump
the polls say about I think it was 53 47
Biden in a hypothetical matchup against
Trump in the popular vote how that would
translate electoral II we don't know
Patrick Nilsson with a hundred Swedish
kronor super chat endorsed Bernie or
else Wow aggressive and Matthew TPC says
David I just signed up Matthew see area
code nine five one yeah so welcome to a
Matthew see who has just signed up and
welcome to Adam Beaver and I already
mentioned Alex Malone okay
one more Super chat here and then I'll
go back to the phone's kcv says I saw
your video with Tim Poole you argue that
religion is a protected class even
though it's a choice
I feel like Tim didn't understand no I
didn't argue that religion religion is a
protected class and religion is a choice
my argument was I think there are
arguments for religion not to be
protected on the basis that it's a
self-professed thing like membership in
a club I don't know if he did or didn't
understand but that that was my argument
okay so we've gotten to our 832 new
member let me scan again for 703 not
seeing 703 let me look for six one zero
not seeing six one zero and then there's
nine five one who just popped up okay
let's go
to 9:51 who I assume is Matthew see is
that you Matthew from 951 it is hello
David hey how you doing that you
appreciate your support up thank you
I've been listening or watching your
show on YouTube for about seven or eight
months now I really enjoyed the content
thank you I had a I wanted to follow up
I asked the question about Bernie and
Allie it was limited to 50 characters I
couldn't frame the question properly I
was hoping I could reframe it for you
got it so I was trying to refer to was
that kind of oh you just you just cut
out you were trying to refer to what was
it Matthew I was saying that a Burnie
get when you're trying to answer my
question but Bernie seems to get kind of
stuck and sort of like you said losing
debates or losing talking points trying
to argue albeit justifiably correct for
inmates voting right right and and what
I meant by digging a hole is that he's
kind of out of step with American voters
I believe it's like somewhere like 77
percent of America doesn't believe in
voting rights are in me and Bernie and
also I agree with you and I mean I think
it may should be able to vote I don't
think America is in agreement with him
and he kept and I feel like Bernie's
getting kind of stuck in that loop I see
what you said that I don't know I
haven't seen that where did you get that
77 percent number I was looking I was I
also occasionally listened to Kyle
kolinsky and he mentioned it and I
pulled up an article kind of broadly
verifying that factoid did the article
site of whole or what was it front it
was from a poll but I can't recall the
actual source of the poll at this time
well I mean let's imagine that that's
true let's imagine that Americans don't
think that felons should be able to vote
while in prison and Bernie does is it so
is it a voting issue like is there a
risk to Bernie from saying that that's
his opinion of people saying because of
that I'm no longer going to vote for
Bernie I don't know like it is felons
voting a voting issue to most people it
feels like it's not but I guess I'm not
totally sure
so the
the question is more is there a downside
to Bernie talking about it if it doesn't
really move the needle one way or the
other and would he be better served by
talking about issues maybe more people
relate to yeah that's kind of what I'm
getting at like I think that he is kind
of wasting time going into so much
detail about it because like it's not
really a voting issue but at the same
time I think it creates some divide with
some center and center left leaning
Democrat that maybe you may be right you
actually may be right and in that case
you know I don't know if it makes sense
for him to continue talking about it in
the same terms you have to remember
sometimes he's just asked about stuff
and and I don't know you know the thing
is if if someone brings it up to him he
shouldn't lie about his position right
so that's what where it gets difficult
if others want to keep bringing it up he
should keep telling the truth about what
he believes right I agree I just feel
like that he should I think he could do
a better job with not being kind of
drawn into it at length maybe more being
a little bit keeping his responses on
his shorter I know that we wonder how
you feel one approach would be he could
say listen there is a debate to be had
about whether felons who are in prison
should be allowed to vote and I'm glad
to have that conversation there is no
debate or there should be no debate that
once felons have served their sentences
they should have their voting rights
reinstated in all 50 states and that's
the immediate goal we should be focusing
on that might be one way for him to
handle it and not not have to start
going in more depth into opinions that
may be unpopular than necessary and just
bring it back to before we even talk
about people in prison voting let's make
sure that we're Rhian franchising people
who have served out their sentences
already right so so kind of like a more
genuine way of how Kamala Harris handle
the medaka for all which he said oh
that's a discussion I like to have and
this you do Don well yeah I mean I
didn't find that to be super genuine so
I think I think it would definitely be
more general than that I think I see
what you did there right yeah okay
appreciate your support and great to
hear from you on the phone all right
thank you okay take care let me look at
a
couple other super chats Anthony burrito
says Biden is so done in my book Bernie
2020 and David Pakman seven days a week
Jesse Duffy has signed up with a YouTube
membership making Jesse new member
number sixteen of the evening CM is
asking why don't you make videos for
expert village anymore
Oh cuz that I did that part-time when I
was like 22 and I've got a real job now
this is it by the way I know that a lot
of people write in and say David when
are you gonna get a real job this
actually is the job see Mills says what
can be done to accelerate immigrant
integration in dense pockets like
Somalis in Minneapolis or Latinos in the
border states community programs yeah I
mean so usually when there are immigrant
communities that don't integrate and
remain sort of clustered together in
what some describe is like an insular
situation it's that there's factors on
both sides and part of it is not
perceiving the community around them to
be welcoming it can be language barriers
so that's something that could be dealt
with directly it can be issues of
housing segregation and transportation
and cost of living there are all sorts
of things that we could attack directly
but it all would be programs that have
to be tailored to the particular
community there's no one-size-fits-all I
don't know too much about Somalis in
Minneapolis I know a little more about
Latinos and border states and the
proscription in one place would not be
the same as the proscription in every
other place so yeah they have to be
locally tailored community programs okay
so let me see if any of our other new
members are holding on to talk to me if
not I will just pick on somebody random
here pick up on that is not pick on
let's go to our caller from the 804 area
code who's calling today from 804 hello
yes that is you you're not on
speakerphone are you I am okay hello yes
oh wow it's much better okay um Oh first
of all I want to say that um I'm so I'm
really happy that uh that you selected
me and I
I'm really excited to be able to talk to
you for a second
very good calling thing I go by Tony and
I'll call from Virginia okay is that but
is that not really your name um it's not
taking my [ __ ] my name but I don't
like their like time say my real name on
stuff like this
alright I hear by Tony how did you end
up with Tony or the name you go by
that's like my new that's like that's
like my nickname my my fan friends call
me okay very good
alright what's on your mind Tony well
I'm rich omnis i was kind of saying that
how much how much things have really i
didn't think about as far as like next
year so i think the elections and
everything and for me like last we mean
give me a couple years ago i didn't i
didn't vote because I just I just
couldn't agree with ain't with what the
people we had be picked really that's
what you know next year yeah I could
yeah like clean and trim I just couldn't
I they were both my paint just really
bad right but I did look at this and I
say you know what next year
I definitely be like playing on both
voting elections I mean yes because I'm
curious if I may have you been following
Donald Trump's to Supreme Court's
elections like you're aware Trump put
two people on the Supreme Court right oh
yes yeah and what do you think about
those people I just really think that
this is a really really unfortunate
situation where I kind of do you think
that um if people did get they get up
and vote then nation of them that they
should have done something dumb ization
of like gotta been voting actually you
know I mean it's like I don't like when
I kind of think they wouldn't probably
been at least a little bit better okay
alright so you recognize that you
recognize Hillary would never have
appointed people like this to the court
and we would have been better off had
everybody gone and voted for her yeah
okay got it all right very good but
we're on the same page there yeah but I
just wanted to kind of like top say that
um I just kind of feel like that um that
uh the way however the way um how organ
is if you know with you swish with the
candidates and everything like I mean
like you know like I kind of agree with
the hosts Bernie Sanders if I'm like
that it's kind of weird thinking because
I want more progressive cool ideas
because I think there's
like a massive given massive issue as
far as like policies and everything yes
but at the same time though I kind of do
think that um there's comedies enclaves
on the left but I kind of feel like that
um if you're not for this candidate then
I'm not gonna be like I'm not gonna be
participate on it I'm gonna stay home
which I highly encourage for people on
the left to not do is to stay home at
least right if you don't like somebody I
mean these both are party reviews cash
to vote out there because the House and
the Senate are am I paying them the ones
that can actually keep least keep this
person and Asian's checks we so use
these are them know makes as much of a
message way to make as we made last
couple years so what's your message to
the voting public vote don't stay home
right that is that the key message yeah
yeah also yeah that's my key message is
to vote don't do not stay home because I
show you will group I always say you
because you're basically basically you
can't complain the next couple years if
you don't go out and vote right all
right and you are a poster child for
that you regret not having voted in 2016
I appreciate you being upfront about
that yeah
all right very good thank you Tom II
Tony from Virginia appreciate the phone
call thank you very very much
let's go oh I have got to thank a couple
of other people Erica D Santiago is a
new david pakman show member and Ciara
Sneed is also a new member Eric and
Ciara really appreciate your support as
well as Tonya Elliott that I think is 19
new members during this live stream very
exciting a crispy critter sent a $10
super chat Ariel Fernandez says any
opinion on Juan Pedone former President
of Argentina I am NOT a pet on ISTA
myself but I am not well-versed enough
in his political philosophy to comment
further blood in the water says Russia's
waging a war of misinformation in
America and appears to be trying to
split the American electorate along
hot-button fault lines like guns race
and abortion will they succeed I would
argue they have already succeeded to a
great degree
sadly Darth Spader says what's your take
on Trump's relationship with China I
think that it's a disaster I think on
the one hand
Donald Trump is making bad economic
decisions in terms of China policy while
at the same time allowing Russia and
China to forge alliances that will not
be
good for the United States in the future
and I think it's mistake after mistake
there
Wade Holmes says when conversing about
the current affairs of the Trump
administration with his supporters it's
clear that any attempt at meaningful
discourse is futile what's your take on
the lack of factual discourse going on
today yeah we need to just circumvent it
so I don't even think it's worth I mean
okay I do a political show if Trump
Trump is Kali and I engage with them
when I'm in you know social situations
and someone says oh I like Trump I think
he's doing a good job or whatever I
don't engage I mean part of this is I
get enough politics on the show so you
know like I'll call my mom and she's
like did you see what I'm like mom I'm
not working right now please I get
enough of this but aside from that I
find that there's very little value in
trying to convince individual Trumpets
of anything it's an exercise in futility
and and frustration quite frankly okay
let's pick up on our caller from the
nine one six area code who's calling
today from nine one six hey Nick what
kind of a device are you using I'm on my
cell phone silva okay very good all
right well what's on your mind today um
hey I was calling to ask you I saw a
headline today that I guess the Beverly
Hills
City Council is about vote to ban the
sale of tobacco products within city
limits I was wondering why I was
wondering what your thoughts were on
that I don't know what the legal basis
is but I loved it I've got to admit I
find people who smoke cigarettes to be
one of the most I mean listen I'm about
to go to Europe on this work trip that
I've been talking a little bit about and
every time I don't go to Europe for a
while I forget that as soon as I get
there people are just smoking everywhere
like in Boston smoking is is less common
than that in Europe and it really ruins
my experience and I find it just
oppressive in every way so listen Tippie
do am i arguing that tobacco should be
illegal not specifically although i
don't understand how cannabis is
Schedule one but for the DEA and tobacco
cigarettes are legal everywhere like
that seems bonkers to me and I don't
know legally if this is going to stand
I have no idea but from a personal level
cigarettes can ruin almost any situation
imaginable and I like the idea that
they're gonna say no snow cigarettes
here yeah the only thing that I could
think of because I'm not a smoker and I
feel the same way that you do the only
thing I could think of that might be a
downside is the loss of revenue because
you know especially in California we tax
it so heavily I don't know how much
revenue we're getting from that that we
would lose yeah I mean does Beverly
Hills need that revenue I don't know
yeah I don't know you know it'll go
somewhere maybe it'll be good for some
other part of La that could better use
the tax revenue I don't know I don't
know but I mean you're making listen
there are lots of considerations there
are financial considerations legal
considerations cultural considerations
I just find people smoking around me so
annoying that I like the idea of it if
nothing else I agree great to hear from
you thank you so much let's go to the
202 area code who's calling today from
2:02 hi this is Sam and I've been
chatting with you over email to David
all right so I have to I have three
questions for you I would have pre
wanted if you maybe just pick the best
one because I've got 37 people waiting
to talk to me right now okay uh do you
how if you're Bernie Sanders and you're
opposed to the death penalty
how would you properly answer the
question that Dukakis arguably gave a
terrible answer to in 1988 oh yes very
good I've dealt with this before so let
me just explain to people what you're
talking about Michael Dukakis was asked
and correct me if I'm wrong Sam my
recollection of it is Michael Dukakis a
Democratic presidential candidate was
asked you know you claim to be against
the death penalty but what if your I
think it was like your wife and/or
daughter were raped and murdered or
something like that
no the exact quote is from Bernard I
think it was Bernard Shaw governor if
Kenny Dukakis were raped and murdered
kitty would you favor the death penalty
for the killer and he said no I don't
Bernard and I think you know that we've
opposed the death penalty all my life
and I know people who worked on
campaign and they and they all agree
that that song ket right so here's how
he should have answered the question I'm
going I'm literally concocting this
right now so it's not going to be worded
in exactly the way I would word it but
it would be some version of listen what
you've described Barnard would be a
invariably life-altering tragedy for
anybody for anyone to have a family
member or anyone violated in that way
would truly be an irreversible traumatic
event and you know what if that happened
I may feel a desire for revenge against
the perpetrator but the United States
should not be in the business of revenge
my emotional reaction should not dictate
whether the state should be involved in
putting people to death period and and
some version of saying it doesn't matter
what my reaction as an individual would
be the question is should we be making
policy on the basis of how I would feel
if my wife were murdered and and the
answer is no okay because I'm kind of
worried that life with Andrew yang I
think he opposes the death penalty and
the Democrats that I like who opposed
the death penalty that like they could
get slammed into the in the debates for
this question and they could and they
could fall the way Michael Dukakis did
yeah it's possible but I mean you just
you need to know that at this point we
have a sense of the different ways that
that issue can be approached and
hopefully there also wouldn't be such a
stupid question from a moderator and you
just got to be prepared and know how to
answer it got it and sign notes did you
hear that the daughter of dart Shane is
thinking about running as a gay
Republican for Senate no I didn't I
didn't hear about that but I will look
into that Sam great to hear from you
really appreciate your call I have a
great day David thank you very much all
right you two take care couple of other
super chats here Arai Suslov asks is
there a way to remove bar eros is Oh
eros is love I always say a racist love
eros is love yes I mean bar can be
impeached a bar could be removed I just
don't think it's going to happen kcv
the DNC steals the nomination from
Bernie again super-delegates can do it
in the second round we've covered that
what should Bernie do endorse the
corporatist again I'm not even gonna
deal with that yet let's let's see how
the primary progresses and do everything
we can to push for a fair primary Friz
junkie says hey David hope you do more
book movie show recommendations love the
show here's another book record I
recommended bad blood by John Kerry Roux
at the top of the show at the top of the
live stream which is a nonfiction book
I'm reading um for fiction I recently
went to my bookshelves and I pulled out
a book that I remember just enjoying so
much when I read it a fiction book for
the first time like maybe 10 or 12 years
ago and the book is Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy by john lecarre a and it's a
book I think from 1978 1974 something
like that and I pulled it out again and
started reading it and it's so good and
I'm enjoying it in a completely new and
novel way because I'm 10 years older now
and it's really great
Ariel Fernandez isn't paradism a form of
nationalists corporatism some define it
that way although in Argentina things
are called different words than what we
often consider them to be Kimmie says
we're in Europe are you going to so I'm
going back to Paris I'm not going back
to Cali I'm going back to Paris where I
was last September involved in an
academic project related to new media
and the timing of it is so Memorial Day
weekend I'm invited to a wedding in
Italy close friend's wedding in Italy
and it wasn't super clear whether that
was going to be a reasonable thing right
going to Italy for a weekend is a little
bit a little bit hectic but then this
opportunity came came to go back and to
do this academic project which I'll say
more about maybe next week in Paris so
it's all coming together it's all
happening and I'm gonna be flying to
Paris doing this thing and then working
my way down to the wedding in northern
Italy and it should be great looks like
the weather will be good I'll be renting
a little stick shift car
in France and driving around and maybe
some live streams from Europe who knows
and Joe says thank you for the great
content shout out to mira vez ciao and
Brody Mulligan thank you very much
and ballin Newlin has said says have you
had a chance to look into the Tim Poole
no-go zones thing you know I haven't I
haven't I saw some chatter in the chat
room yesterday related to that and it's
not something I've looked into but I
know that what people have told me is
that he makes claims about no-go zones
in Sweden that are not accurate I think
would be the gist of it but it's not
something I've looked into in detail
okay I've got a run of busy busy evening
still ahead thanks to everybody who
joined me sorry that there are still
people holding that I couldn't get to
thanks to the 19 or maybe 20 new members
oh and I'll answer this have I watched
these is ech
jiseok Peterson debate and do I have a
thought about doing a long-form analysis
I watched the debate I watched like half
the debate at 1.5 X speed I was not
impressed I don't think any new ground
was broken I do believe that jiseok is
the intellectual superior but I think
that the debate really fell flat and I
have no plan of doing a long-form
analysis they've been done and I'll
leave those to other people
Ariel Fernandez says buy in a super chat
by everybody I'll do another live
streams